thank you thanks for the invitation to
the program and the boot camp and so I'm
gonna pick right up where Daniel I left
off talking about sis so talk about the
learning with errors lwe problem some
applications and also an outline of the
hardness proofs for lwe so just like sis
where Daniel E showed us the worst case
to average case reduction there's also
such a reduction for lwe but it's more
more involved and a little more subtle
and there are some nice open problems so
let me just say at the outset you know
please feel free to interrupt you know
raise your hand ask questions I prefer
to get a lot of questions so this is the
outline uh what will we will recall sis
which was you know done an hour and a
half ago so you might have forgotten
some things and then we'll introduce lwe
and then we'll talk about a few
cryptographic applications and then
we'll talk about at least at a high
level the proof of hardness
so first we'll define learning with
errors and give some perspectives about
how it relates to its it's counter
problem sis okay so let's just do a
reminder from from two hours ago or so
the first is our short integer solution
problem first defined but I think not
named by I type in 96 so the problem has
two main parameters at dimension N and a
modulus Q and you can think of this Q as
being relatively small maybe a small
polynomial in n typical choice and we're
interested in looking we're looking at
the set of n dimensional vectors of
integers with mod Q entries and mod Q
operation so the SAS problem is as
follows
the Challenger gives the SAS solver the
attacker several uniformly random
vectors from this zqn domain so some
large number of them m and the challenge
is to find given these uniformly random
vectors find some non-trivial small
combination of them integer combination
of them that adds up to 0 so we're
looking for small integers e 1 through Z
M that are not all 0 ok all 0 certainly
works but we want a non-trivial set of
numbers so a non-trivial set of small
integers such that this sum adds up to 0
and all the arithmetic here is modulo Q
ok so each each of these vectors you
know maybe we take one of these and two
of these and negative one of these
should add up to 0 mod Q so that's the
goal we can write this a little more
compactly as as a matrix and vector
multiplication so we take these columns
a1 a2 through a.m. and just bunch them
up into a single matrix a then we have a
matrix which is height n and with M and
then we're looking for short nonzero
vector Z such that a times Z is
so this problem would be easy if not for
this short requirement okay so you could
solve this problem easily just using
Gaussian elimination but it's going to
give you a very large vector Z whose
entries are roughly Q or so Q over to
maybe but we're looking for a vector all
of whose entries are very small so
that's what makes this problem more more
difficult okay so that's sis and as
denne denne showed you there's a
collision resistant hash function that
we can get from this from the problem or
assuming that this problem is hard so if
we just take this matrix a as the
uniformly random key to the function and
then we define the function f of X as
just a times X and the domain here is
binary vectors so 0 1 vectors of
dimension M and then those hash down to
a vector in zqn so the domain is larger
than the range exactly when n is larger
than n log Q so this is a compressing
function and it's collision resistant so
what this means is if you can find a
collision in this function for a
randomly chosen a then you can break sis
right and how do we do it well if you've
managed to find such a collision so
that's an X and an X prime which are
different from the domain where ax
equals ax prime then just subtract ok so
you subtract and you get X minus X prime
this is a non zero vector all its
entries are 0 plus minus 1 and a times
this is Z equals 0 just by the fact that
ax equals ax prime ok so this should be
review from one last time but any
questions
so that's kind of the the first first
application of sis so it is useful also
to look at SS itself as a lattice
problem and to do so we imagine taking
this matrix a that we had the force of
this uniformly random matrix a we define
an object called L perp or the perp
lattice or orthogonal lattice of a is
just the set of all vectors integer
vector Z such the a Z equals zero so
this is defined without regard to the
norm of Z right so this long vectors the
short vector to see everything so looks
something like this and a few easy
observations about this lattice are that
it's kind of it's Q where E is the term
for it or it's closed under shifts by a
Q okay so this point here is zero comma
Q and Q comma zero this is in these are
points in the lattice just game is zero
my Q and this corner of QQ is as well
and if you just look inside this box and
you shift the box you know by Q in any
direction you get exactly the same same
thing so this is kind of periodic modulo
Q but all the interesting stuff is
happening inside
so that's the lattice the L perp of a
and you can think of a is like a parity
check matrix if you're familiar with
coding theory the term for a here's this
parity check matrix for the
so what is s is asking for it's asking
for a short solution or that is a short
nonzero lattice point okay so given a
defines this big lattice with with all
these points all over and the goal of SS
is to find a short vector in this so
that in this way we can see sis as like
an average case short vector problem on
this kind of random lattices one other
concept that we'll meet as a idea that
there's also cosets of this lattice so
here's the lattice with the origin
included and then we can ship the
lattice maybe a little bit to the left
or up and down or however you want to
move it if you shift the lattice that
corresponds to a coset and we use this
notation here so l purpose of you this
is just the set of all integers vectors
where AZ equals u so u equals 0 is this
is the actual lattice but if you choose
some nonzero u that corresponds to a
nonzero ship and that can be seen as
just the set of the original solutions
plus a particular solution okay so the
homogeneous solutions plus a particular
solution all have the form where u
equals a times T so that's the cosa and
this would be called like the
inhomogeneous sis or Isis as I like to
call
or before the recent unpleasantness
before the recent unpleasantness yeah I
mean Isis goes back to ancient Egypt
right it's only lately been soiled okay
so I'm a genius problem the homogeneous
problem whichever you like is this what
you can use so what we have here which
Daniele showed us is this remarkable
worst case - average case reduction for
SAS which says that there's a reduction
where if you have an algorithm to find
short nonzero vectors in this lattice or
even in a random coset of this lattice
for a uniformly random a then you can
use that algorithm to solve various
lattice problems in the worst case okay
so on any n dimensional lattice and the
there's some quantities here that are
important so the bounds that we need is
the length of the vector should be at
most some bound beta that we fix in
advance and beta should be substantially
lower than Q okay you can always find
vectors of length Q like this one here
but if you fix beta to be substantially
less than Q then finding lattice vectors
of that bounded norm is as hard as
approximating lattice problems two
factors roughly beta at times root n so
there's this root n kind of slack I
guess between the length of the SAS
solution and the approximation factor
but typically we said beta to be some
small polynomial in n or maybe just a
bit more than a polynomial but in any
case these these approximation factors
are are very hard to obtain
so this is the the nature of sis it's
really remarkable because it says if
there are any hard instances of these
problems then this problem here is hard
for a uniformly random choice of you can
actually generate any questions about
the yeah this is the iterative
production the one-shot reduction would
be much worse in okay so that's the sis
review and kind of yeah figures are not
drawn to scale
here yeah so I wish if we had like a
hundred dimensional board I could show
better pictures but just one thing to
note is like this point here you know is
negative two comma one normally you'd
have a lot of lattice points inside of
this but even I mean any even reasonable
size of the ball will have a lot of
solutions in it not just two
morally what sis looks like okay so now
let's let's put the page I flip over to
in fact it's kind of the other side of
the same coin to talk about lwe okay so
lwe was introduced what almost 10 years
after I tie by reg F in 2005 and just
like SAS it has the same parameters N
and Q again think of Q as polynomial
doesn't have to be but it's most useful
to think of it that way and it has one
more parameter which is an error
distribution so the error part is new
here and here is the problem okay so the
there's kind of two flavors of LW either
search and decision so let's tackle
search first so the idea of search is
that there's a secret vector s in zqn
and the attacker is given many random
noisy inner products with us so what
does this mean
just like before we have these random a
1 a 2 a 3 up to am hey these are chosen
uniformly from zqn and then we give the
attacker these a 1 a 2 and so forth we
also give the attacker s inner product a
well not exactly we don't give it
exactly s inner product AI we give it s
AI plus some noise okay and the noise is
drawn from this error distribution so a
little more precisely if bi is s inner
product AI + e eye where the eye is
drawn from the error distribution and
the typical error distribution that we
consider because it's very friendly for
the the proofs and for how the systems
behave is like a Gaussian like error
distribution like this so zero is here
in the middle with the highest
probability plus minus 1 of almost that
probability plus minus 2 a little bit
less plus minus 3 a little bit less than
that and it tails off quickly beyond
there ok so the parameters we usually
think about our Gaussian looking error
distribution with a standard deviation
of about square root
and that's gonna be much much less than
cute so think of this error as covering
basically an alpha fraction of all all
of GQ so centered at zero kind of as a
width of alpha times Q okay so again the
problem is given these AI bi pairs with
noise and the B is to find this secret
and I'll just mention that well let's
let's first write it a little more
concisely so just like we did with sis
we can we can bottle up these AIS into a
matrix a so again the columns of a are
just the vectors AI from before but we
also have one more thing which is
basically s times a okay so we basically
have a row combination of this a matrix
that's inner product each of these
columns that's like multiplying us on
the left
that's times a but there's of course
some noise added to every entry okay so
it's given a and B find the secret S or
equivalently find the errors okay so one
observation immediately is that if there
were no errors or if you knew what the
errors were then you could easily solve
this problem this B would be exactly s
times a and then just using linear
algebra you can solve for s so it's the
errors that make this this problem
that's like refueling it Jeff okay so
good the errors are what makes this this
problem difficult that's the search
problem the decision problem or decision
flavor is asking you to do something a
little more mild seemingly more mild
which is simply to just distinguish
whether you're given an a/b pair that
was created in this way or whether you
were given a uniformly random a B pair
so the uniform movie random case there's
no secret there's no errors B is just a
random uniformly random vector
independent of okay okay so all you have
to do is tell your promise to be given
either this or this and you just have to
tell with some advantage which of the
two you got
okay any question about this so far so
just like we have for sis we have hard
worst case the average case reductions
also for lwe the story's a little more
complicated however so what here's what
we have we can show that search lwe okay
so there's let's go from left to right
there's a reduction from worst case same
two problems gap SVP or SI vp to search
LW e where the approximation factor is
now like an over alpha okay so alpha
being the rate of the noise so the
smaller the fraction of the space that
the noise covers the larger of an
approximation you get so you you know if
you want a harder problem you should
pick a larger rate of noise that's kind
of intuitive sense that this quantifies
it so you get an N over alpha
approximation out of if you have an
algorithm to solve search lwe now the
catch here is that this reduction here
is a quantum reduction okay so no matter
what kind of algorithm you have for
solving search lwe it transforms into a
quantum algorithm for these problems
over here so even if this is a classical
attacker this becomes a quantum attacker
this is a quantum attacker naturally
this is also quantitative
but this reduction kind of introduces
quantumness into the so that's kind of
interesting you know as far as we know
and and conjecture these problems are
hard for quantum and so that still is
evidence for the hardness of search lvv
but you might like something more so
we'll talk about that later and then
there's a second step which goes from
search lwe to decision all the beliefs
so it actually shows that these problems
are essentially equivalent via this
reduction here and that actually goes
back to a paper by bloom at all from 93
but just that was for learning parody
with noise and it generalizes quite
quite easily to this more general case
with a larger problem and so it searches
hard then decision is hard and then
assuming that decision is hard we build
crypto systems most most crypto papers
will say you know assuming lwe we do
blah blah blah and that's usually the
decision lwv assumption
so that's the kind of picture it's not
the entire picture there's some
alternatives here so there is also a
fully classical reduction from a
worst-case lattice problem to search lwe
it works for worst parameters and only
works for gap SVP talk about that on the
third part of the talk but it does give
you some you know it removes quantum
from the picture I'll be it to a limited
limited degree
and then we'll talk about this more in
the next talk where it's more relevance
but there's also a direct reduction
which goes from worst case problems to
decision lwe skipping over entirely the
this intermediate search that still
quantum but it's kind of interesting
more in the ring settings
so any questions so far about the
existing landscape of productions
I'll do something okay in class there's
a good trick you can try
I require a question okay I won't go on
until so this is a fully classical
reduction with worse parameters still
from sadp no no no only from that gap
s50 yeah so I have more to say about
that at the end
okay so just like for sis we can look at
lwe is the lattice problem and it's kind
of instructive to see it in this way I
feel if you don't then indulge me but I
think it's useful to speak this way so
just like we had the sis lattice this
defined by a like L perp obey there's
also an LW e lattice and we can define
it as follows so I couldn't call it L of
a and it's basically treating a as a
generator matrix for the lattice or the
code so this is all the integer vectors
that are congruent to s times a for some
for some s and a nice exercise to show
which you can do in a couple of lines is
that actually this is the dual lattice
of the sis lattice it's a dual of L /
pay up to a scaling by factor Q so the
LW that is actually the dual of sis
lattice
scalable appropriately and it's the same
argument if you take in a coding theory
class the dual code you given a parity
check matrix that defines a code and
then the dual code is generated by its
gen by that treating that matrix as a
generator matrix so exactly the same
proof of this just quite nice
but lwe is now not like a shortest
vector problem anymore
it's a bounded distance decoding problem
on this LW less so that is well we're
what we are given is some vector well
there's some vector STS times a here
it's a point in the lattice
but we've perturbed it by adding some
noise and so we're given that perturbed
point so given B which is close to some
s times a the goal is to find you know
find that nearest lattice point so if
you can find V then basically you can
factor out s so that you've removed the
noise so you can solve for s well for
there
so that's the that's Alda beauty as a as
a BDD problem
and what's important is that the amount
of error that we add is typically very
small compared to the like minimum
distance of this lattice so there's a
unique answer this B is very close
relatively speaking very close to some
lattice point is guaranteed to be and
your goal is to decode it to the nearer
you need so that's that's the BDD view
of lwe or you could say well distinguish
a B which is very close to the lattice
from a uniformly random point in space
that would be the distinguishing or
decision problem
so in summary we have this kind of
picture we have SS here on the left
which is an average case short a Spectre
problem
you have the perp lattice ll perp of a
and the goal is to find a nonzero point
within a pretty wide radius a radius
where there's lots of solutions and in
elbow B we it's a bounded distance
decoding problem on the average where
you're given a point guaranteed to be
very close to the lattice and the goal
is to find that unique nearest lattice
point so and of course this lattice here
is the dual of of that lattice
so any questions about this
so I think that concludes part one yes
it does so the last thing I'll say about
this is for in Danielle's talk he showed
applications of sis which are all like
mini crypts primitives okay they all are
things you can get generically from
one-way functions and SAS gives you a
one-way function without W II the this
allows us to get into crypto mania so
lets us build public key encryption and
a whole lot of other very fancy things
which are also public key encryption
type primitives so the fact that we have
this kind of unique solution it seems
somehow to be very important for getting
like inject injective one-way functions
and public key encryption and things
like that so there's a qualitative kind
of change of a qualitative threshold
that we cross when we go over to the
world
so now let's talk about some
cryptographic applications of lwe and
along the way we'll have to give some of
sis as well so not everything here will
require lwe but in EA on the way we will
build some things out of sis as well so
first an overview we can build an
amazing amount of stuff from lwe so a
lot of kind of cryptographic primitives
all the basic bread-and-butter public
key encryption stuff so we can build pke
and key exchange we can build oblivious
transfer we can get so this this appear
refers to passively secure or CPA secure
public key encryption we can also get
chosen ciphertext secure encryption CCA
secure encryption with or without random
Oracle's more recently we can get
pseudo-random functions or constrained
pseudo-random functions that have nice
applications so these are kind of
bread-and-butter things then we can get
more exotic objects like identity based
encryption with or without random
Oracle's even make it hierarchical more
recently it's been shown how to get non
interactive zero knowledge proof for all
of NP without random Oracle's and and
more much more in this category and then
we have things where we couldn't even
build them using any previous assumption
like fully homomorphic encryption or
attribute based encryption for very rich
access policies so these are things
which are completely new or we're
completely new at the time they were
built to the field of crypto but now you
know we can build them from lwe or
lattices and that's more or less still
the only thing we know how to build them
from just
so that's a brief sampling these are the
things of all of these things is what
I'll cover for the next 40 minutes or so
we'll do all of these we'll do a couple
of these yeah you bought it you bought
it we can do it okay so let's just do a
couple of these the most basic one is
public key encryption so this is you
can't do any of these other things
without knowing the public key
encryption system so this is the most
most basic thing that everything else is
based upon so this was given in reagan's
original work although we're introducing
a twist from GPB okay so here's the
public key encryption first we're gonna
choose this matrix a and you can think
of it as the receiver chooses it in key
generation or you can think of it as
it's say it's used by everybody right so
some trusted party picks a random a and
everybody uses it
either way you like this will work okay
so Alice here is the receiver and so
she's gonna generate a public/private
key pair her private key is just a short
vector X a short integer vector X and
her public key is just a times X so we
we just apply the SIS hash function
basically to oh it's a secret key to get
her a public key and one fact that you
can prove using a well-known lemma
called the leftover hash lemma is that
the public key is uniformly random if
the parameters are set properly okay so
if this matrix a is wide enough you know
what it was shaped like this
and we have n rows and if you have much
more than n log Q columns then Alice's
public key is just a uniformly random
vector
good so that's her public key and a
private key and now Bob comes along and
he wants to encrypt a message to Alice
let's say he just wants to encrypt a
single bit so single bit encryption is
sufficient so it's complete
so here what he will do is basically
create an lwe an elbow be vector okay so
he's gonna pick another beauty secret s
and he's gonna do s times a but add some
error to it and notice that this doesn't
have anything to do with Alice's public
key so he can do this kind of in advance
or whatever he doesn't need to use
Alice's public key for this but then the
after the preamble he actually writes he
also takes s times Alice's public key s
times a plus noise and s times u the
public key plus some noise as well
and then he does this curious thing
where the bit he wants to encrypt the
message bit
he adds either 0 times Q over 2 or 1
times Q over 2 so basically to send a 0
this is just s times u plus error to
send a 1 it's s times u plus error but
then flip to the opposite side of Z Q
cycle
okay so that's the payload which carries
the message bit and he sends both of
these things to L now how does Ellis
decrypt anybody see it leave it as an
exercise as L says the user shorts
secret key to decrypt here what can we
do
yeah multiplies the key the key X by
this here yeah so imagine I take take
this term here and multiply by X on the
right right and what you get is s times
a times X well that's s times U and then
you get e times X as well now so you're
gonna get s times u plus something small
it'll be e times X e times X is small
and this also is s times u plus
something small so these you can
subtract to cancel what else we'll do is
take this B prime minus this B times X
and if you do the calculation that we
just did what you end up with is this
term here you know carries through this
term here essentially cancels out with B
times X except there is an e times X and
a little EEP prime carried through but
the key point is that E and X are both
short it is it a short error X is a
short vector so e times X is pretty
small and if you set up the parameters
correctly eat iams X is much smaller
than Q over 2 so essentially alice is
going to get the vit times Q by 2 plus
some error which is not very significant
compared to this so this is either 0 or
Q for - it's a little bit perturbed by
error but you can just see which it's
closest to and that tells you the
message bit
that part clear
so these cancel out and we're left with
E prime minus E X these are both small
and so if these are much smaller than Q
over two you can recover
so that's why it works this is why you
can decrypt using your knowledge of X
now let's look at security okay so
suppose there's some eavesdropper and
the eavesdropper gets to see all the
stuff that's public the public sent over
the channel so the eavesdropper knows
the effect sorry the matrix a the public
key you and then these two components of
the public key so the thing to notice is
that let's look at this BB prime
compared to a in you right so a and u is
really just a uniformly random uniformly
random stuff a was picked uniformly and
then U is also uniform by our choice of
parameters so this is just like a
uniformly random matrix and this vector
here is basically s times multiplying s
on the left by these two things that's
times a and s times you that's what be
and be primed with error so if you if
you just ignore ignore this part here
these two things here by the lwe
assumption are pseudo-random so they
look to the attacker like truly
uniformly random vector B&B in the crime
okay so that's completely and and if we
replace these red b and b prime with
truly uniform ones then those hide the
bit information theoretically so that
just perfectly hides the bit so by
switching the ciphertext to have this
form now the bit is perfectly hidden so
that's like well the one-line proof of
security for this crypto system early
CPA security
what a question about about this so far
what's the difference between this demon
rightness yeah so okay great great
question so what's the difference
between this and ribs the rolls are
basically reversed and reg of scheme
this part is Bob so Bob has the public
private key this part is Bob's public
key and this part is Bob's secret key
and this is part of the ciphertext and
well this is computed differently by
Alice so if you squint at this and look
at it in the right perspective what's
basically going on here is the difficult
type key exchange where this part is
like Alice's Alice's message that this
part is Bob's message and they are both
able to compute something close to s
times a times X using their respective
secrets they can something like s times
a times X with some noise that is what
acts as the denominator
so that's just kind of rearranging how
you look at this okay so that's the the
public key crypto all lwe based
encryption has this at the core of it
there's as far as I know no other way to
do public key encryption with although
if you wanted to make a square yeah
exactly so there's a paper by Richard
Linder and myself following on idea from
Lib moshevsky Palacio and Sega which
uses a square matrix a this U is ax plus
error and and this is also s times a
plus error you have to be careful the S
then is not uniformly random but it also
comes from the error distribution and it
turns out that that is safe to do so
less s can be drawn from the error
distribution without losing any security
so with a couple modifications you can
make a square
and there's a way to encrypt from it'll
use to build a trap door when we're
functioning
yeah my function right it's uh it's it's
kind of the same right the sender is
still sending this and then well okay
that one degenerates to this one I guess
yeah if you're one vector in the trap
door that's all you need to decrypt
gotta see the same thing well more I
guess a more powerful version of it
okay so those are some variations of
public encryption you can do but they're
all basically morally saying
okay so for a second application what I
would like to talk about is digital
signatures for signatures all we need
actually is sis it's this is going to be
different from Danielle a I think showed
the one time signature and then kind of
put that into the tree based framework
we're gonna give a different kind of
digital signature scheme here which is a
many time scheme so here's how it works
at a high level and I'm gonna steal a
little bit from Shweta 'z talk I think
tomorrow right or maybe Friday Friday so
I'll give a little preview Shweta will
give many more details but here's the
the main idea
okay so digital signature scheme we have
a signer who should create a
verification key and a signing key so
the verification key is just a random
matrix a as always but this is created
in a clever way
together with what's known as a trapdoor
T so I won't tell you well I won't tell
you yet exactly what form this trapdoor
takes but I will tell you what it allows
you to do so there's some special strong
trapdoor here and here's how we're gonna
sign messages so to sign a message mu
you use the trapdoor in the following
way we are going to first thing we do is
we hash the message let's say using a
random Oracle into zqn so we take the
message which might be like hi Bob how
are you today we apply a random Oracle
that gives us a random vector in zqn and
then the signature that we put out for
that message is a randomly sampled short
solution to ax equals hash of the
message
so how do we do this I'll tell you in a
moment but this is the idea right so
we're gonna sample a short solution to
this equation here to be a little more
precise what we need to do is to draw
the signature X from a distribution
which doesn't reveal information about
the trapdoor so this is going to be some
kind of oblivious sampling algorithm and
concretely what we will do is draw X
from a Gaussian distribution so there's
a whole set of solutions to this
equation there's lots of short-short
vectors X that satisfy this equation and
we're going to randomly choose one
according to a Gaussian distribution
okay so all of these represent the
various solutions we're going to choose
one from this distribution here which is
it's only over the the solutions X
okay and what's important is that
distribution this distribution is kind
of independent or oblivious to the shape
of T so it reveals no information about
deep it's just a Gaussian distribution
okay so let's see how someone can verify
such a signature and why this signature
scheme is is secure so to verify the
signature the verifier has the public
key a the message itself and some
candidate signature and what the
verifier does is just hashes the message
as before okay so you get to this random
Oracle applied to the message and then
we just check that ax equals the hashed
that's the first thing we check and then
we also check that X is sufficiently
short so it should be a short short
enough solution to this equation and if
so then we accept the signature as
legitimate otherwise we will reject so
is it clear how to how signing and
verifying work essentially
let's now look at the security of this
but it's just a very high-level
idea of why this is secure so for
security in order to forge signature for
a message so suppose the this the forger
wants to sign you know produce a
good-looking signature for this new star
then what the forger has to do is to
actually find a short vector X star such
that ax star equals the hash of new star
but this is exactly the SAS problem okay
the random Oracle hashes the message to
a random vector vector u so we're really
just saying okay find me a short
solution to ax star equals random vector
u and that is the SAS problem okay it's
the ISIS problem
so this is why well this is why you know
informally it's hard to find a signature
of course in the signature foraging game
you actually have access to a signing
Oracle which can potentially help you
produce this forgery and intuitively the
signing Oracle is producing signatures
from this distribution and this is kind
of a zero knowledge distribution that
doesn't help you okay so you have to do
the proof of course in the random Oracle
model but intuitively seeing a bunch of
signatures just gives you a bunch of
random vectors from Gaussian
distributions which you could
essentially generate yourself so that's
the the high level security
let me take a question about this
yeah like the trapdoors magic right I
haven't told you how to do what it looks
like or how to do these things do it on
the next slide but yeah for now just
assume there's a trapdoor which allows
you to do this so good it allows you to
sample from Gaussian distribution over
the solutions to this equation
and I'll show you imminently how that
actually works
okay so as an exercise
break break this scheme I lied a little
bit it's not secure you can break it you
need a little tweak to avoid at breaking
spectacularly not you okay don't spoil
it yeah yeah
do you actually break it you can I think
you can I think you can break it
yeah well unless the parameters are
extremely tight and I think you can
break it
so does that mean that there's something
that you told us here that's incorrect
something I've told you is uh not
complete I guess I'll give you a hint so
this this random Oracle of MU you the
way to fix the problem which I won't
tell you is to add some randomization
through the hashing so when you hash mu
actually choose some random salt along
with mu and hash you and the salt
together and then include the salt in
the signature
so the vaguely enough defined operation
here it's okay
so that's the yeah
yes
good yes so it's it's claimed to be a
many time scheme that is you can sign
basically an unlimited number of
messages the the attack I have in mind
is related to the many time it doesn't
really have I suppose it has to do with
the fact that a is used it's the same a
through all the signatures there's a
specific kind of many time signature
query that you should issue
I guess not despite the thought you
generate the seems to be domestically
with me cuts
so yeah many time is another hand
okay so let me let me tell you a little
bit more about how to implement this
operation here so again the goal is we
have a trapdoor
which has some form I'll tell you about
and the goal is the sample Gaussian
distributed solution to this equation so
okay good I wrote it here so again the
goal is sample an X such that ax equals
some target vector U and the trapdoor
that we will have is going to be a
particularly short basis T of our
lattice so we have the sis lattice and
what what one can do is to actually
generate an sis lattice with a random
matrix a together with a short basis of
that lattice so the the signing key that
Alice knows is itself basis made up of
shorts lattice vectors okay a complete
basis of the lattice and in particular
let's say there's some upper bound on
the length of the basis vectors that
upper bound will be the standard
deviation of our Gaussian so again the
advantage of this is that this
distribution we're sampling from
actually doesn't leak any information
about the basis itself like what is
geometry is the public rather the upper
bound on the basis vector basis vector
lengths will be known so that's a that's
a public value but nothing more than
that is known about the
okay so here's how to do it the
algorithm is rather simple to describe
pictorially more work to do formally but
the idea is to run the nearest plane
algorithm did you do the nearest it was
ok so nearest plane algorithm but with
some randomized rounding instead of
deterministic rounding okay so here's
the idea we have the co set L per pave
with Co set you and we want to draw from
this distribution here right so we have
the shifted lattice and let's say we
have these the vectors t1 and t2 which
are a basis of the unshifted lattice
right so if I were to put the basis if I
were to put the lattice at the origin
these vectors would regenerate their
lives ok we want a sample from the
shifted lattice under a Gaussian
distribution so here's the approach it's
an iterative algorithm what we do is
imagine partitioning the coset according
to the multiple of t2 so this we kind of
have a plane and another plane and
another plane another plane where within
each plane they have the same multiple
of t2 but but you know arbitrary
multiple of t1 ok and then we in the
nearest plane algorithm what you would
do is just start at the origin and round
off to the nearest plane that's where
the name column
but we will round off to a randomly
chosen plane with a certain probability
so the most likely plane we choose would
be this one which is closest to the
origin but maybe by chance we happen to
choose this plane instead so we pick a
plane at random which is near the origin
and then we project from the origin on
orthogonal e onto the plane and then we
just iterate so for iteration or there's
only two dimensions here so when we
iterate now it's a matter of rounding
off within this plane to a nearby
lattice point all right nearby Kosovo so
maybe we randomly round off to this
point
so if you do N in in general in n
dimensions you would do n stages of
rounding to a nearby plane and then
working within that subspace and doing
it again and again and again until you
end up at a point okay so that's the
algorithm just round off to a nearby
time
and what's remarkable is that this
actually does for the proper parameters
sample from this nice clean Gaussian
distribution I'll give it just the
highest two line okay three line summary
of the proof if you look at this
distribution over here and you look at
the total probability mass assigned to
each of these planes it turns out that
the amount of prep the probability mass
assigned to each of these planes is
depending only on the distance from the
origin to the point so it doesn't matter
how the points are shifted within each
plane there's essentially a smoothing
argument which shows that the
probability mass basically only depends
on the distance of the plane and so what
that means is that if you round round
off to each plane with the appropriate
probability which depends only on the
distance then you are kind of sampling
from the right distribution marginal
distribution at each step and then
overall the final output has
so that's a that's a three line proof
encapsulating the key idea of the houses
okay so any question about that
something like no yeah the the angles
between the basis vectors is irrelevant
all that matters is that the
gram-schmidt vectors actually of the
basis are smaller than the standard
deviation of this distribution so I
wrote that the vectors themselves are
shorter than the standard deviation but
in fact this gram-schmidt lengths are
all that matters so yeah any two bases
that satisfy this bound will generate
the same distribution in the end and and
that's what I mean by the the output
distribution doesn't leak anything about
that basis almost essentially up to a
tiny statistical
good question any other question about
so I'll just mention I think Shweta will
probably on Friday talk about other
ideas this is not the only sampling
algorithm that it's not the only notion
of a trapdoor you don't have to use a
basis necessarily so there's other ways
to accomplish this same goal which you
can then plug into signature scheme you
know from the previous slide
okay so that's how we can get signature
schemes from sis but it turns out that
there's a lot more that we can get from
this technique here this kind of
oblivious Gaussian sampling and one
thing that we can get to give away the
the punch line a little bit as something
called identity based encryption so this
was a concept proposed the Shamir in
1984
hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo identified the issue
that when you do public key encryption
you have to get the receivers public key
you have to know it belongs to them so
to answer this we've built the the
foolproof airtight you know public key
infrastructure so this is an alternative
to like the public key infrastructure so
Shamir says suppose that there was a way
to generate a public key and a secret
key or these for the master public key
and master secret key and then you can
have many different users user specific
public and private keys underneath this
this domain here so that is if we could
have many users there's Alice and Bobby
and Carol here and the central authority
generates their secret keys for them so
their secret keys are produced by the
authority and they don't have public
keys well for their public keys or their
names or the name or the email address
or something like that
so if you want to encrypt a message to
Alice for example you don't need Alice's
public key you just need the master
public key and then Alice's name and you
can encrypt a message
and you could do the same with Bobby and
Carol you can encrypt messages to each
of them individually using only their
name
and the advantage of this of course is
that you don't need a public key for
each of the the people in the world you
just need a the one master public key
and you need to know the name of the
person you're the transferred person
naturally Alice can decrypt this message
but the idea is that Bobby and Carol
should not be able to read
and one way we can formalize that is to
say that if Bobby and Carol actually
were adversarial and even combined to
their secret Keys together they used all
the secret knowledge that they have they
still can't violate Alice's privacy
still carry her
so that's kind of the the informal
requirements of a identity based
encryption scheme and for a long time it
was not known how to build it so that
changed in 2001 Binet and Franklin gave
an IDE based on this kind of new math or
at least new math for cryptography these
bilinear pairings and then it came out
that I guess a few years before
Clifford talks they built an IDE based
on quadratic residue ASSA T was the same
guy who invented RSA before ours they
did and then and with the stuff that
we've seen so far we can do it with
lattices as well so here's the picture
actually we've done everything we need
to get identity based encryption it's
all in this picture so if you remember
the public key encryption scheme from
before it looked a lot like this but now
what does the difference Alice doesn't
choose her own public and private key
they're kind of chosen for her or more
specifically the authority generates
Alice's secret key for her and she has
no public key she just has a name so so
let's see how this works
the master public key is this matrix a
and the master secret key is the same
trapdoor T that we used for the
signature
and now again instead of Alice picking
her own secret key the authority chooses
it for her specifically it's going to
choose a Gaussian X such that ax equals
well the hash of her
so instead of having like well I guess
you could consider this as her public
key but it's it's kind of correspond to
her name right anybody can map her name
to her
so by hashing her name you get her
public key you or her identity public
key and that her secret key is just a
short acts such that ax equals you
so it's important here is the
relationship between Alice's private and
public key is exactly as before you can
imagine that X X is just this short
vector and her public key is a times X
that was exactly how the public key
encryption scheme worked before it's
just we're kind of choosing m in a
reverse reverse way first we hash her
name to get her public key and then the
authority samples
so that's it everything else is
identical the encryption works just as
before so Bob if he wants to encrypt a
message to Alice well he can hash her
name to get her public key on his own
and then do everything as before they
just in critters
so any question about this series
Rossini the salty good yes so that the
the salting idea a good observation does
not work here because and it's not clear
what salt Bob should use so the other
thing to do is the one that the Vinod
spoiled which is to do a deterministic
sampling where you use like a
pseudo-random function as your source of
readiness or you can do something like
only give Alice her key once great yeah
then then yeah so so what this this
whole like identity based encryption
ecosystem relies on the authority only
gives Alice's secret key to Alice right
Alice has to show that yeah they
I'm really Alice and I'm not Carol right
yeah if you could if you could
impersonate somebody and steal their
secret key from the authority that's
obviously a problem so we should imagine
here that only Alice knows this X Bobby
you know we'll get a different hash and
so we'll get a different X prime or
something
yeah that's good good
other questions or concerns remarks
okay so this is just a flavor a tasting
of what we can do with lwe and tomorrow
and Friday they'll be much much more
building on these ideas so for the
remainder of the time what I'd like to
do is give an idea of the worst-case
average case reductions for lwe and
these are going to that kind of souped
up versions of what Daniela showed in
the in the talk this morning
with new elements to them and accounting
for the nature of lwe as a bounded
distance decoding problem
so let's just recall what we know about
lwe this is the the state-of-the-art the
picture of the reductions worst case
lattice problems from the left quantumly
reducing to search and then decision lwe
also a classical reduction with with
worse parameters and problems and then
this will be later
so what all these results have in common
is a core component which works is which
works as follows it's a it's basically a
way of turning a BDD instance on an
arbitrary lattice so a worst-case BDD
instance into lwe samples so there's a
machine basically which kind of
randomizes a BDD instance into lwe
samples so here are the the two pieces
of input that this component requires so
what I first need is a BDD target and
what I mean by this is we're talking
about bounded distance decoding on a
lattice l2 within distance D ok so what
I mean here is that there's a target
vector T and it's within distance D of
this lattice cell and this is just some
arbitrary of worst-case lattice so T is
close to close to V with at least
distance D of a vector in the lattice
and then the second input to this
component is many discrete Gaussian
samples okay so still this picture yeah
so this distribution
I have I want to take many I want to be
given many samples from this
distribution where the width of the
distribution is roughly R over D oh and
this distribution is over the dual lives
so we have one target many such Gaussian
samples and notice that the the
dependence on D here so the width of the
Gaussian is inverse inversely
proportional to the distance
and what this component does is given
these two kinds of inputs it's going to
generate lwe samples the elbow bv
samples will have a secret s that
basically corresponds to the closest
vector of the solution to BDD so the
secret s basically is lying a little bit
in one-to-one correspondence to the
vector V and the amount of error in
these lwe samples is basically R that is
it's the product of the distance bound
and the Gaussian width the width of it
so the e times R over D ok so why is
this interesting it's very interesting
the first thing is that if you had a lwe
solver right if you had an Oracle which
takes these lwe samples and tells you
what s is well then that's basically
telling you what P is solving BTB for
you take your BDD instance run it
through this machine get all the beauty
samples solve lwe and then that tells
you what the original
so that's why this is a useful reduction
and in its worst case to average case
these this lattice is arbitrary but
these are legitimate properly
distributed all the beauty samples so
that's the core component everything on
this page uses that as the heart but
then builds things differently around it
okay so let me first tell you about ray
gives original iterative quantum
reduction it's very nice
let's suppose that we start with well
not just suppose that it we will we will
start with
the goal would be to solve BDD to a very
tiny distance so some some distance D
which is really really much smaller than
the minimum distance of the letters our
goal is to solve BDD you to this tiny
radius well we put it through the the
machine that core component that I just
told me perfect so if I've got what I
need then it's the place that really
wide Gaussian samples over the dual
lattice and then my machine can produce
lwe samples given a target here and a
bunch of samples from this we get lwe
samples we can invoke our lwe oracle and
that solves BDD force so with a very
wide and with a very wide Gaussian I can
solve BDD to a very tiny good now here's
the really cool idea one of the one more
really cool idea is to say well if you
can solve BDD to this tiny radius it
turns out you can quantumly generate
samples from a slightly narrower
discrete Gaussian so there's a quantum
step which will say solving BDD to this
radius gets you allows you to generate
discrete Gaussian samples from a
narrower
now this is narrower than that and so
this is a narrower than that what does
that allow me to do well it allows me to
solve BDD to a slightly wider radius so
let's let's do it again let's say okay
now if I have a BDD to a slightly larger
distance I can combine it with these
narrower samples and then using my old
OB we solve or still solve BDD here
that makes sense and I'm doing something
pretty pretty fancy and subtle here but
we can repeat this being able to solve
BDD to this larger radius lets me
generate even narrower discrete Gaussian
samples in a quantum way and so that
lets me solve BDD to an even larger
radius up top and I can just go back and
forth iterating this eventually it stops
working and stops working when these
samples get so narrow that they actually
suffice to solve s IV PE and gap SVP so
being able to generate very narrow
Gaussian samples is more than you need
to
so this is the structure of Riggins
quantum reduction very nice
going back and forth between BDD and
sampling using one to solve the other
better and repeat this is quantum the
natural yes question here great okay
so yeah where it may be the question is
like where did these come from right
like where did the first samples come
from very good yeah so at a very wide
radius like an exponentially large
radius you can generate these yourself
for example using the algorithm I showed
with a really bad basis okay so yeah
that that's very important yeah so this
thing gets kicked off just by you can do
it yourself and then these you need the
solver to generate it was given to you
as yes yeah these are all over the
original L star this love is a little oh
well this is over the L star and this
one is over L decide which question
which problem you want to answer and
then define Ln L star accordingly okay
as beautiful intuition why
yes right yeah so good so why does
solving BDD - this radius allow you to
generate samples of this form here right
so the rough answer is that solving BDD
- this radius allows you to generate a
quantum superposition which you can
think of as like tiny little Gaussian
centered at these lattice points so
imagine just a very spread out widely
spread out narrow gaussians centered at
all these lattice points and if you take
the Fourier transform of that
superposition it ends up being
corresponding for this distribution so
this step here from here to here is a
qft no no no the opposites so it would
be non-invertible so you can generate a
superposition of these Peaks but there's
some extra junk correlated to it there's
an extra register with junk correlated
to it and you need to get rid of that
junk you can do that for sure
yes yes okay right without BDD yeah to
make reducing this peak modal artisan
maybe to generate this yeah so generate
I have more in the next slide so that
okay so yeah so the question is like why
quantum whereas quantum being used here
so the obvious answer that I just gave
is in this iterative step right so being
able to solve BDD allows you to generate
these samples that goes that that uses
the quantum Fourier transform in a
essential way it'd be great if we could
do this step without quantum but we have
no idea how to here's maybe a better a
slightly better answer a more detailed
answer at least is to actually be able
to usefully employ the BDD Oracle okay
so this is the I think what Daniel I was
just referring to how can we create this
superposition here well you can choose
some V and then you're gonna add some
error to it and then you could think of
like invoking the BDD Oracle on T and
what do you get back
hey all right you get back for you we
already knew P it shows V yourself to
start with it's right there right so the
Oracle is telling you something you
already knew seems like it's useless
right it's kind of a zero knowledge
Oracle I guess for it's telling you
something you already knew so how could
this Oracle be useful but the point is
that in a quantum realm the quantum can
uncomputable you get back V and you can
use it to uncomputable V and this the
idea is used in to produce this
superposition no we want to generate
such a superposition that is we want to
generate a superposition of Gaussian
centered at a lattice points singly
what's the random lattice point like
what what's the idea of starting at an
arbitrary lattice point yeah okay so you
can you can work modulo the lattice and
not have a V in the picture at all but
that's okay
yeah okay good so instead of choosing a
V just start with the perturbation and
then reduce it mapa lattice but then you
have to forget the amount you shifted it
by when you did this reduction well how
do you forget it you invoke the Oracle
to tell you what it was and then on
computed great mysterious stuff but
that's quantum
okay so once you forget V then you have
the superposition you like and you can
do it each other
so that's the that's the why quantum but
maybe you don't like quantum or maybe
you don't want the quantum reduction you
prefer classical reduction so here's one
way to avoid the quantum it doesn't
entirely resolved or doesn't give you
everything that the quantum reduction
gives you but it gives you something so
the key idea is there's an alternative
way of solving just GAAP SVP it doesn't
work for SI P P it does work forget this
VB so here's the usual picture you know
you start with V you add some
perturbation you invoke the Oracle it
tells you be something you already knew
so that seems useless but imagine as a
thought experiment a different world
where your lattice now looks like this
so the lattice is kind of maybe dense in
a certain direction or has a small
minimum distance so imagine doing the
exact same process on a lattice that has
such a small minimum distance you start
with V you add some tea you invoke the
Oracle what does it tell you
well the key insight here is that this
is actually if there's a few things
wrong with this this doesn't make any
sense this is any illegal BDD instance
where we're perturbing T by much more
than the minimum distance Plus this is
going to create an incorrect bizarre
unknown lwe distribution when we run it
through the reduction the samples won't
look proper at all but doesn't matter it
doesn't matter who cares the point is
that if your minimum distance is much
less than D the Oracle simply cannot
guess the original vector okay there's
some ambiguity about where you started
did you start here or did you start here
to get T so the idea is that on the
normal case the the usual world where
the minimum distance is large the Oracle
will return to V but in this world where
the minimum distance is small the Oracle
provably cannot return the V or at least
can't always return v that's some
probability of not returning V and so
this actually allows us to distinguish
the case of a large minimum distance
from a smaller
so that's at least the kind of a core
idea there's a lot of oh I should
mention this actually can be viewed as a
if you know the goal break goal boss or
proof system can be viewed as some kind
of version of that between the reduction
and and so I'll just mention there's
some technical obstructions to making
this work for example hey where do we
get the pegasion samples from you need
those to run the reduction we don't have
quantum so we can't generate them
quantumly but you can do that if you
have some some basis for all-star you
can run the sampling algorithm so
depending on how good your basis is the
modulus will be essentially equal to
that and for example you can use an LLL
reduce basis that's a 2 to the N to the
M good basis so your modulus is
exponential so this is whatever is
referring to with like worst parameters
this Q it's kind of only works with an
exponentially large modulus unless you
assume some better basis is available
and also this is a one-shot thing it's
not iterative and it doesn't work for SI
DP and particularly distinguishes small
minimum distance from large but it
doesn't actually find short vectors like
yeah I mean I suppose in this non
iterative maybe is an advantage but it
comes with this these prices yeah so I
don't view it as maybe a disadvantage or
at least its implications are additive
okay search decision equivalence is also
an issue you have to get over because
previously this was only proved for
polynomial moduli and this is an
exponentially large modulus you can get
around this by using a smooth q and uh
and and Gaussian error maybe another
exercise if you break the the decision
if you break the digital signature
scheme
okay or as we'll say in the next talk
you can just reduce directly to decision
without using search as an intermediate
problem and that's that's an alternative
thing you could do
so this basically addresses all the
technical things that come up when you
try to use this approach any question
about this
so it's asked to talk about open
problems I'll tell you my 4 favorite lwe
open problems they're in decreasing
order of difficulty maybe although who
knows okay so the first one is to
actually get a fully D quantized
worst-case hardness proof for lwe so get
get something which works for the same
parameters as the quantum reduction also
works for SIV P you know the whole ball
of wax without any sacrifices that would
be fantastic I don't think anybody has
any idea how to do that yet
okay then the next two are about
applications so one thing that I
mentioned in applications is that we can
do fully homomorphic encryption from lwe
but to get really fully homomorphic
encryption that is with them with no
bound on the what you can evaluate
homomorphic li you need a circular
security assumption so far so this is
this is a big problem like get unbounded
fhe without any circular security
assumption just get from plain lwe okay
here's a problem I'll put on the white
board up on the second floor once it's
properly formalized and it'll be worth
$15 yeah yep
fifteen dollars can be yours for solving
this problem so I would like an adaptive
Li secure ibe without random Oracle's
but has the same efficiency as the
scheme in the random Oracle model so the
random Oracle model scheme is adaptively
secure
I want one without random Oracle's but
without giving up efficiency in fact we
can do this in the standard model of
shredder we'll talk about this we can do
it in the standard model but only for a
weaker selective security notion so also
getting adaptive security I think we
don't know how to do this yet
and then a fourth problem has to do with
something I didn't even define but it's
a nice question
I think so there's lwe and then there's
something called LWR the R stands for
rounding and the idea is instead of
adding random like gaussian errors you
just round off round off to the nearest
multiple of 10 or something like that so
it's a determinate it's a way of like
making the errors deterministic and we
have some hardness proofs for this
problem it's learning with rounding but
they're not very good they're much
weaker than what we know for lwe and LWR
is a nice nice problem maybe there's
good hardness results maybe there are
actually better algorithms for it we
also don't know any algorithms that
perform appreciably better than for
random error but I think this is a
really interesting direction that hasn't
been really looked at enough so that
would be a great problem to work on so
happy to touch out more about these
problems
[Music]
[Applause]
it's this deep pointed exponential yeah
for the the modulus is now has to be
exponential and it does not work for si
VP there's no classical reduction well
not for the standard like gap SVP
problem as as usually defined as I
mentioned there's this notion of if
you're given a Zeta good basis so if
you're given a basis that's like better
than an l-dub lll reduced one you can
get a higher you can get a better
parameter Q but there's a little bit of
a non-standard kind of problem so
investigate that problem more it would
also be a very
that's that's make you smaller right so
really the problem is si VP for which
both Bo Bo Paris makes Q smaller at the
expense of making n bigger and n log Q
remains the same so it actually doesn't
it doesn't improve the parameters at all
it just makes the parameters more I
don't know more palatable I don't know
they look nicer yeah it doesn't actually
improve the price and the air is much
worse rate error well or worse in which
way yeah the the error rate I think
remains the same roughly the same
that this other rates the these whether
it's classical or quantum they have
basically the same behavior in terms of
error rate of lwe and and how that
translates to an approximation factor so
that that we can't expect to improve or
there's nothing to improve their
classical versus quantum but parameters
other parameters could be
thanks again for your attention
[Applause]